hi in this module i'm going to present
the particle filtering algorithm for
performing approximate inference in
hidden markov models which is really
useful when the size of the domain of
the variables is very large
so let's start with our familiar object
tracking hmm
in this case for every time step we have
a position hi of an object which we
don't see
and instead we see some noisy sensor
readings
so the probabilistic story of object
tracking is as follows
each one the first object position is
generated uniformly
across all the values zero one two
subsequently h2 is generated addition on
h1 via this transition distribution
which goes up
with probably one quarter uh stays the
same with probably one half down with
probably one quarter
um
h3
now at each time step we get a sensor
reading
e1 e2 e3 condition on the respective
locations and that's governed by the
emission distribution
which takes high and goes up by a
quarter
is the same with
half goes down with probably one
so now you multiply all of these local
conditional distributions together and
you get one glorious joint distribution
over all the object locations as well as
the sensor
readings
that's rh
so now given this hmm we can ask all
sorts of questions uh on it in
particular we looked at filtering and
smoothing questions
the particle filtering as the name might
suggest does filtering so let's focus on
filtering
so in filtering we're asked
asking for
the position of an object at a
particular time step condition on the
past
the time step one we're asking for
i'm looking at only the evidence at uh
time step one and i was like where is
this object
um at time step two i now have two
observations now i ask where is the time
object at time step two
it's time step three i have three
observations and now my four words
object at time step three
so now i could apply forward backward uh
algorithm to
this scenario um
and that would work but
the problem is that there's if you have
a setting where there's many many
location values for each eye but in this
in our simple example there's only three
but in practice you're going to be a
hundred thousand
and in that case four backwards is going
to be really really slow
because its running time scales
quadratically with the number of to have
a hundred thousand squared which is not
a nice
the goal of particle filtering is to
realize that well you have a hundred
thousand possible values but only a very
small fraction of them are really uh
likely given the data out
so to start
introducing particle filtering let us
revisit beam search because structurally
particles and beam search are analogous
so in beam search remember the idea was
to keep track of at most k
partial assignments which we're going to
call particles now in the particle
filtering lingo
so beam search starts with a candidate
set of only one assignment which is the
empty assignment
it's going to go through each variable
in turn from 1 to n
and now we're going to for each of these
partial assignments for our h1 through h
i minus 1
i'm going to take that
and then i'm going to consider all
possible values i can assign to hi
i'm going to extend that assignment so
now we get a bunch of assignments from
h1 to hi my i
and now i'm going to compute the weight
of each of these candidate particles
and i'm just going to take the
a highest weight particles
so let's recall
beam search on this example here
um here we have our object tracking hmm
we have the variables and all the local
conditional distributions and i'm
observing zero two two
beam search starts out um
extending to variable h1 and it produces
um
zero one and two are the possible
particles with weights
um these probabilities here
and i prune which does nothing because k
is three
and then next
i'm going to extend
to h2 so each of these particles um
kind of multiplies
into
three particles
and now the weight
of each of these particles is going to
now include
the factors which are the transition
into h2 and the emission maybe e2 equals
two given h2
um now i'm going to
room
down to three
i'm gonna now extend to h3
and i'm going to prune
um
and at the end
i get
a
set of particles so here i have zero one
two
um i have one
uh so zero one one i also have a one two
two and each particle has
some weight
normally in beam search we're interested
in them uh
presented in the context of finding max
weight assignments so in this case you
would just return onto two
but in the case of particle filtering
we're interested in answering
um filtering queries
so what we're going to do instead is
we're going to normalize the weights
over all the particles to perform get an
approximate distribution
over assignments
and now we're going to pretend this is a
joint distribution over h1 to hm given
evidence
and now i'm going to adjust some
probabilities to get any approximate
smoothing query a filtering query you
know i like
um
so
this is fine
but it has two problems with it
one is that
the extend step
is slow because it requires considering
every possible value
of a chi
so sometimes you can be clever you don't
have to enumerate all the values in the
domain and um
you can only uh enumerate over values
that are going to have positive weight
but even that could be a lot
so the second problem is that
we are greedily taking the
a particles with the highest weight
so
um this is going to as we'll see later
doesn't provide enough diversity
so
we're going to have to do something
about it
so particle filtering is going to solve
both of these issues
and particle filtering is going to
contain three steps to replace the
extend prune
two-step procedure of beam surge
so propose weight and resample are the
three steps and we're going to go
through the turn
the first step is propose so in general
you should think about the set of
particles as an approximating a certain
distribution
in general the filtering distribution is
the probability of the variables that
you are considering condition on the
evidence so far and suppose we have just
two particles here
um zero one and one two
so now
the proposed step is
um going to take each of these particles
and i'm just going to sample
a value for h3
the next variable
given the transition distribution
remember was
up and down with probably one quarter
and the same the same way same with
probability half
so that is going to produce these
extended articles um conditioned on the
same evidence
so
for example i'm going to take 0 1
i'm going to
uh
now that will produce
um each this particle with probability
half
because uh i'm just keeping
the the value the same here
and i'm going to take this particle and
i'm going to extend it to 2 and that's
also going to happen with probably half
now this is a random algorithm so i
could have sampled from the distribution
i could have gotten one here
i could have gotten three here but let's
just go with one two
so in the next step i'm going to
wait
so you should think about these
particles
as
a guess as to what h3 is going to be
but we need to fact check this guess
with evidence
and so the waiting part uh step is going
to
assign a weight to each
particle
and that weight is going to be the
probability of the new evidence i got
conditioned on
h3 here
so
this is going to produce a set of new
particles which are weighted
representing the distribution
on the
h1 h2 h3 condition all the evidence so
far
so
let's work out this example so for the
first particle i have h3 equals one
so h3 equals one it's going to generate
the evidence e3 equals two with
probability one quarter so i have a
weight of one quarter attached to the
first particle the second particle
um
has
this should be a two here actually so
the second particle has h3 equals two
and i'm going to look up this table and
that's going to
um have weight one half because the
probability of generating a two given a
two is one half
so i have a weight of one half on this
particle
so now at this point
i have a set of particles
that represent
the
advanced um
filtering distribution
but
notice that the weights are not the same
and some weights are small some weights
are big
and in particular the particles with
small weight
are kind of wasting
space
you should think about the k particles
as kind of a limited resource for
representing this distribution so if you
have a particle with weight 0.0001
or maybe even 0 then certainly we
shouldn't be wasting one of the valuable
k slots for that
value
so what we're going to do is to
reallocate our resources via resampling
so in the resampling step we're going to
normalize these weights
and draw k samples so normalizing these
weights produces
this distribution one-third
two-thirds
and now i'm going to draw k-samples from
that distribution so redistribute
so the
resulting particles are still going to
represent
the same distribution but slightly in a
different way without weight
so um
i'm going to sample
maybe i get
1 2 2. i got that with probably two
thirds
sample again and maybe i get the same
particle again
two-thirds
now of course this is again a random out
algorithm so i could have gone the first
one
and the second one or the second one the
first one or the first one the first one
so
now you might wonder why are we
resampling why leave the result of the
algorithm up to chance
so to see why consider the following
setting so we have a distribution over a
bunch of possible locations
and suppose that distribution were very
it's very close to uniform so you can
see
maybe you can see that there's a slight
um
higher probability in the middle
but it's pretty flat
so now if you did beam search which
takes the k
possible positions with the highest
weight you would end up with this
and so you would end up with all the
particles clustering around the middle
which is really not representative of
the distribution
because you have all these positioned
out here with
a non-negligible probability masks which
have no support so it's kind of like
putting all your eggs in the same basket
or the same cake baskets i guess
um so instead if you re-sample or sample
from this distribution k times you're
going to get something more like this
which i would argue is more
representative
of the distribution
so
in cases where
most of the weight is on a few locations
sampling versus taking the top okay is
not really a big deal
but when there's high uncertainty as in
this example
sampling is really important because it
allows you to maintain
uncertainty
so now we're ready to present our final
particle filtering algorithm which is
again structured very similar to beam
search
so like beam search we initialize with
the empty assignment for each of these
time steps we're going to propose wait
and re-sample so here we're going to
propose
we're going to take each
assignment to h1 through hiv minus 1
and we're going to
look at the transition distribution and
generate
one possible
uh assignment to each i and i'm just
going to take that so in b search i'm
going to consider all of them
which can result in a blow-up but in
particles i'm going to only look at one
now i'm going to weight
the particles based on
the evidence which is this emission
distribution
and finally i'm going to redistribute my
resources by
normalizing this weight distribution
and drawing
a particles independently from that
distribution
okay so let's see a demo here
so here i have my object tracking hmm
i'm going to run particle filtering with
100 particles instead of view search
so
i'm going to start out with
extending to
the
just the first
variable
and now i have three part well i have a
hundred particles
but um 38 of them are zero 33 of them
are one and 29 of them two
and these are the weights
i
resample and now i redistribute
probability to
um zero and one with these particle
counts
so now i'm going to extend
and
notice that
before i had 73 particles at zero now 51
of them go
to h2 equals zero and 22 of them go to
h2e1
um
and then i'm going to
resample
which redistributes the particles again
now i'm going to propose and
re-weight now all the particles
are
all over the place
and now i redistribute mass
so that the particles are
used more effectively
okay so now at the end
i have now a
100 particles
covering all these different assignments
i can simply
count the fraction of them
for
that satisfied various values of h3 and
i get my approximate filtering
distribution over h3 condition
okay so there are two
ways to make particle filtering more
efficient
so particle filtering we've casted
in terms of generating a distribution
over
complete assignments to all the
variables
but if you're only interested in
filtering queries which
look at the last variables
then what we can do is instead of
storing all
um the assignments we only we only need
to keep the value of the last hi so it's
i'm going to only look at
h3
because this is sufficient to
continue the algorithm forward
and furthermore
if you have
are multiple particles that have the
same value you can actually just store
the counts as we saw in the demo one
occurs twice and two occurs three
times now let's visualize particle
filtering in a more realistic
interactive object tracking setting
okay so here
we have a grid
um and we have an object that's going to
be moving in this grid
where we're trying to determine its
location
so
the hmm is going to put
have a transition distribution that
places a uniform distribution over
moving north south east west or staying
put
and the emission distribution is going
to put a uniform distribution over
locations that are within
three steps either vertical or
horizontally so you can kind of see this
definition of this emission distribution
which only depends on the
x-distance and the y-distance and it's
going to look at
um a uniform distribution over
basically a box
okay so if i hit ctrl enter here we can
see the observations they're very noisy
and we're trying to guess where the
object is so i don't know where
somewhere um
so what we're going to do is we're going
to
run particle filtering let's say we have
uh uh 10 000 particles
we hit control enter again and now what
we're going to see
is um a red blob
and this represents where the particles
are
with intensity
of the particle representing the number
of particles at that particular
location
so you'll see that
this is our kind of best guess of where
the object
is
okay so you can see how well we're doing
by
showing the true position
so let's see where this object actually
is and we'll see that we're tracking it
you know rather well
um sometimes i think you'll notice that
it might mess up but on the whole it's
it's pretty good
so also notice that um
you know
the
the red blob where it thinks the object
is is not fooled by where the
observation is because there's enough
noise here
um that
um what
a modeling
the particle filter is doing is that
it's essentially kind of smoothing out
the noise the noise is jumping around a
lot but it's kind of tracking and knows
that the object can't be teleporting and
it's moving um only
by one step at most each time step
so you can play with this demo a bit
more um
we also have implemented um instead of
this box noise you have gaussian noise
which looks uh kind of similar
more of a spherical blob um you can also
play with it there's kind of really
weird looking noise which
places uniform distributions over all
positions on this uh
lattice that have a certain kind of
parody
okay so in summary we've presented the
particle filtering algorithm which
allows us to
answer
filtering questions of the following
where is this object at a particular
time step given
evidence so far
and the key idea is using particles to
represent
this approximate distribution
so remember particle filter mean uh has
three steps which
is used to advance
um the set of particles first we propose
when we take article and
transition them to the next time step
we uh this is a guess of where the
object is going to be at the next time
step
then we're going to
fact check our gas by re-weighting the
particles based on the mission
distribution of what we actually saw
and then we're going to reallocate our
resources by resampling and this will
allow the particles to occupy
the regions with a higher weight
so unlike forward backward algorithm
this particle filtering allows us to
scale up to cases where there are large
number of locations
and also unlike a beam search
it allows us to maintain
a better particle diversity especially
in situations where the distribution is
close to uniform
so now particle filtering is also called
a sequential monte carlo and there's
many many more sophisticated extensions
that i haven't covered in particular
particle filtering works for general
factor graphs not just hidden markup
models and i encourage you to read up
and learn more about it
that's all